alright let's talk about our friends
over at the NSA they're not just reading
your emails and tracking your phone
calls they're also following what video
games you play which is why I'm happy
that I'm still on Sega Genesis playing
ghouls and ghosts they are tracking you
on World of Warcraft second life and a
bunch of other online games this is
according to the New York Times The
Guardian and ProPublica the NSA and it's
British counterpart which is the G chq
the UK's government communications
headquarters I think that's where James
Bond used to work if i'm not mistaken
they are spying across gamers all over
the world because it's sort of a they
believe it to be sort of a secret zone
that terrorists can talk to each other
not just guys sitting in a basement
getting fatter and playing games spy
agencies are worried that these games
serve as a good cover for terrorists to
use in-game messaging systems to swap
information recruit other users or carry
out virtual weapons training so that's
two things they can chat with each other
in the games and by playing the games
you might learn how to use an actual
real weapon and the NSA was extracting
world of warcraft data trying to tie
specific accounts and characters to
islamic extremism and arms dealing
efforts i mean this sounds completely
crazy the GCHQ had successfully been
able to get the discussions between
different game players on xbox live and
so many US spies were roaming around
second life that a special deconfliction
unit was set up to prevent them from
stepping on each other's toes I mean
really think about that we've got so
many people spying that they they're
spying on each other this is becoming
spy verse pi is this just like another
one of these things where its first it
was our emails then our buddy lists then
our phone calls and our facetime video
chats and now of course this was just
the next logical step right oh yes this
is what they've wanted all along this
total information awareness you know and
they want to be able to infiltrate every
single corner of every single pixel
everywhere throughout the entire world
because that's what they believe is
important also I think they want to play
video games at work
but I really believe that like I bet you
that a good percentage of these guys are
literally just playing games all day
sure why not wandering around second
life just to see if they can bump into
each other and of course they're only
bumping into other spies and think
what's important about this is that they
still have yet as far as the paperwork
shows they still have yet to prove that
there's any evidence of this activity
going on yeah so okay it goes from one
thing to another I mean I'm guessing
you're not surprised I'm not surprised
and I almost wish I didn't know you know
what what I what I don't know is not
going to hurt me if they're watching me
play video games whatever I'm not doing
anything wrong but it is I mean it's
like being rather they're gonna jump all
of you for saying that yeah I'm not
doing anything wrong we're right of
course but I really don't care if
they're you know listening to my phone
calls or reading my emails I have
nothing to hide but I understand the
there you know invading our privacy at
what point is the net too big to protect
us on a larger scale while we're doing
this for the good of everyone we gotta
maybe read your emails and fish through
your phone calls because we're trying to
find the terrorists that could be taking
down you know yeah we could have another
911 right I get it even though there's
no whether it's enough no right of
course but but then if they don't do
something then people are gonna be like
well you weren't doing enough right I so
I I don't know yeah the incentive is
obviously you don't none of us want to
find out that this could that some huge
major attack happens and it could have
been prevented if only somebody been
wandering around second life nobody
wants that right well yes but yet so so
so yeah there is gonna be blatantly say
he's gotta get leg is something that's
how I am currently so we're always
dealing in the what if that happens well
we should have been new Madison
rectification for many things the I
think the other side of it and you know
granted you know none of us were
probably doing anything to be afraid of
in so many words but that's not the
issue the issue is abuse of power sure
you know the abuse of this information
to maliciously prosecute people or
maliciously blackmail people because you
know things about them in this life that
they have the expectation of privacy
well we was also broke last week that
they were tracking potential terror they
were tracking their porn use because
they felt they could then use that
propaganda because it shows that they're
not honest and they're not really that
it for terrorists but do we actually
know that that's why we're looking at
they weren't looking at congressman for
example they weren't looking at
political opponents right you could
blackmail literally it's actually
happening in the world right now I mean
we don siegelman former governor of
alabama in prison now a political
prosecution so you know look it up you
can get more information on that he's a
direct person watching porn to me that's
only a good thing because i think stress
right and they're distracted their relax
i think they probably will have a lot
less angst and maybe want to keep living
instead of blowing themselves up along
with all their other people well that's
the thing but they were saying they were
saying that this is the way if you can
find out what porn they watch then we
can humiliate them and that hurts the
cause that was that was the argument but
how much did the companies that make the
video games microsoft let's say who
makes xbox how much responsibility do
they have to actually protect the
virtual world that they are making i
think they're more interested in
protecting their profits and protecting
the kinds of legislation that will help
them maximize their profits i think they
really don't particularly care whether
or not you know gamers don't trust them
anymore at some point i think if you
don't want to be on the radar do not be
on the radar don't have a cell phone
don't play online don't use the world
wide web go live in a cabin in Alaska
where you go out and hunt your own food
you don't have cable service you know
what I mean very well sure exactly i was
just watching survival or something on
that geo and there was a guy that had
been living out literally and remote for
us hadn't seen people you had to be like
hey I'm friendly is that okay if I come
towards your house you know cuz he lives
it chooses to live out in the middle of
nowhere not be connected to anything so
I'm just saying that you know as a
person that if you're on a phone it can
be monitored if you're on the internet
it can be monitored if you're on a game
box that's connected to the world you
want to play some random dude in nor we
you know in Norway then you know that
there's a possibility that somebody can
tap in or that somebody could be
watching or listening okay sure there's
a possibility but I don't see why we
have to put up with that so that's what
so that's a final question on this is
what do we do because as i started this
every week so you think the answer is
just to shut it down altogether but i
don't know how realistic that is right
we all have this stuff human progress
when you can't have a job with your
having
right you can't function in society
really without this so what is their
minor steps that we can actually take
two to fight this growing and
encroachment us what happens it's a
pendulum and it happens every couple of
decades here in the United States
Eisenhower warned us about this you know
the military industrial complex well
it's the military intelligence
industrial complex now you know we're
spending a ton of money on these guys to
play on video games but we don't happen
to have money for food stamps or happen
to have money for veterans you know this
is the kind of [ __ ] we have to deal
with I think part of it starts with
electing the right people to Congress
and also making sure that we put in
place the kinds of investigations and
then the kinds of controls that we've
put in place before it's not like we
haven't had this conversation in this
country before it's just had taken a
different tack